[__] how's Social Club doing it's too
tough bro uh I mean bro we built out an
app that allows you to upload pictures
videos text post you could put your
whole menu if you're a Trapper or if you
have a store you can put your whole menu
of products in price for free attached
to your profile we're putting audio
comments and audio caption
right no other platform has that but no
one will will [__] with the platform I'm
burnt out on it I'm thinking about
giving up on it again that's the one
business I can't figure out which is
Tech it's tough man it's tough because
like you're competing with like I mean
but think about this so we're competing
with a a platform that doesn't give a
[__] about any of us all our [__]
shadowbanned I had someone at Facebook
tell me yo you got 2 million followers
you should be at 13 million followers by
all the ways you've been searched by all
the stuff that you've done the
accomplishments you've made there's no
way I was stuck at 1.9 million followers
for 2 years you mean to tell me I was on
the cover of forest magazine and my
followers didn't go up 100,000 at all
yeah [__] that she was like you should
be at 13 million at least but they're
capping your growth well I think what it
is man is unfortunately like everyone's
going to go where the attention is right
so if you like a [__] business owner
you want to be where everybody's at it
just is what it is so it's like in the
same way that like you know like YouTube
unfortunately you know there's other
YouTube uh competitors that have popped
up that like rumbled and [__] like that
but you know it's like if you got a you
if you got a Content Channel you kind of
have to depend on YouTube in a certain
way because you want if you want your
[__] to scale for real that's where the
eyes are it's hard to get people to
squitch from Instagram I've offered
other celebrities equity and Social Club
to help me build it's like nah man it's
not going to work you know I'm like bro
I put you know over what like $2.5
million in a social club to I'm trying
to give away Equity to people just help
me build it like n man it's not going to
work It's just tough cuz you're compe
you're competing with these guys in
Santa Clara and the Silicon Valley you
know I'm
saying I mean at some point people are
going to get sick of having their posts
deleted you know so I think I think
what's going to happen hopefully is once
weed probably becomes federally legal
there will be probably like a need for
like a real platform like social club
because it's going to be such a uh it's
going to be it's just I feel like there
there there's got to be there's going to
be a weed platform
20 years from now well if you sell weed
if you smoke weed if you post weed you
should know this 100% Mark Zuckerberg
[__] hates weed he does not want we
yeah you've had your [__] yanked before
Shadow I mean I've heard it from the top
I'm from here I live in the Bay Area I
know people that work with the homie and
so basically he just doesn't like weed
keep your keep weed off IG you don't
want your Pat [__] with or just join a
social club and post your weed there
like don't be a [__] [__] start up
an account if you really claim you Trapp
or die [__] you put your menu up for
free right now on my [__] yeah you know
[__] [__] with me hey man Social Club I
got a profile go follow me on there yeah
I got a profile no one really interacts
on there that's the sad thing I'll be
honest but it's going to take us to
build it man cuz I I I don't even like
going there and getting like no respons
I get like 40 comments and [__] but like
at the end it's a good platform if we
all move over there then it's you know
[__] it is what it is